the prime minister is holding a meeting
of the cobra emergency committee this
afternoon following the taliban's rapid
advances in afghanistan it comes as 600
british troops prepare to deploy to
afghanistan to provide protection and
support for british nationals trying to
leave
well i'm joined now by paul farving a
former royal marine commando who is in
kabul paul really glad we managed to get
through to you to talk to you about this
i've i've been looking at what you've
been tweeting as this situation out
there deteriorates but before we talk
about your feelings on this can you
describe to us the situation there right
now
and right now here in kabul it is
absolute panic
um
i've never seen anything like it at all
um there are thousands of refugees now
coming in from all over the country
i'm hoping that kabul is going to be
their last
hope of you know safety um and it is
just desperation everywhere it's
heartbreaking absolutely heartbreaking
you mentioned that word hope uh one of
your tweets says western governments
gave young generations of afghans hope
for the future they abandoned them to
the wolves do you still feel that way
absolutely um
you know it takes a couple of
generations of people you know to
actually change a society um and
you know we had given them all the tools
you know we've given young women hope
you know aspirations for the future
um we'd give an opportunity to go to
school you know some of the young women
who work for us here at our charity you
know they were only young girls when and
the taliban removed from power and they
took that opportunity for education
they now work they choose their own
career paths
even have you know their own
options now they want to marry for love
not because someone tells them to
and we have literally
we have just thrown that away we have
just pulled that rug from under their
feet and said sorry get on with it um i
am i'm absolutely
just i'm in despair i just cannot
believe we have done this to the afghan
people after everything that was
sacrificed for the last 20 years
this is what we've done and you of
course have
uh paul witnessed those sacrifices
you're a former royal marine how does it
make you feel on a personal level you've
talked about the sacrifices mate
457 british uh soldiers have have died
and you know of course hundreds of
thousands of deaths and injuries in
afghanistan how do you feel about this
um i lost two of my young marines in
helmand back in 2006
and i truly now want somebody to tell me
what was the point
um
[Music]
i i have no words absolutely no words to
describe
um the hurt the upset the confusion
um and i've been talking to a few of my
colleagues and friends who also served
out here in afghanistan and they are
just absolutely shocked at how
the politicians have decided that yep
we'll just give up on afghanistan
um no i have no words we i'm ashamed
absolutely ashamed to be uh part of what
has just happened
the prime minister is holding an
emergency cobra meeting here this
afternoon um paul i'm not sure if you've
heard we've just broken the story and
they are now sending british troops back
to afghanistan not to fight but to get
britons out um will you be amongst those
people trying to get back to the uk to
safety
right now um i'm going to say no i can't
i cannot just leave my staff behind
um you know as i said we've got young
women who work for us you know what do i
say to them well i've got a british
passport and
you know boris is sending the troops in
to get me out but sorry you've got to
stay
whether or not i can i honestly don't
know whether i pop my staff in more
danger by being here
um is something that we're actually
discussing now
um um and yeah right now i couldn't i
couldn't tell you and give you an honest
answer uh my heart says i've you know i
want to stay and i want to be here you
know you know for my staff and
especially we've got an animal shelter
here
you know what do i do with the animals
um
you know it's just absolutely
heartbreaking and to see
everything that has been worked for for
the last 20 years thrown away
i have no words absolutely have no words
i i can see the distress
on your face and i can hear it in your
voice paul and it's what you just said
is really striking that you're not sure
if your presence will actually put them
in danger i mean what a difference from
how you've spent the last few years
crucially but and that is because
you're worried presumably that the
taliban is making such
speedy advances that they may well march
into kabul and and cause people their
harm
i mean that that's what everybody here
is now
concerned about i mean the taliban are
literally a hundred kilometers away from
kabul um you know as i sit here now um
and their rapid advance over the last
few days you know has literally taken
everybody by surprise there really has
been no
resistance against them
um and i you know i hear now obviously
the americans are sending in 3 000
troops the british are sending in 600
you know to get us you know westerners
out
well why didn't they do that just to
force the taliban to an actual peace
negotiation table
why did we just hand afghanistan back
um i i am literally
like i said just unfounded
we could have made the taliban go to the
peace negotiating table and actually
have peace here in afghanistan
but we didn't somebody somewhere needs
to answer for that
the lives lost the money wasted the
future's destroyed
it is not acceptable somebody somewhere
needs to answer to this paul do you feel
betrayed do you have a message for boris
johnson
i'm not just boss johnson but to all the
western leaders yes absolutely i feel
betrayed i know every single serving uh
soldier who has been out in afghanistan
any veteran
who lost someone who sacrificed so much
they will truly today be saying what was
the point
and to the afghan people
i can only say sorry
um because obviously you know i'm
british
um you know it's my government that's
made a decision so
i i can't say sorry to him because we
have left them to the wolves and that is
just unacceptable